[Musique]
vous êtes plus de 91.000 qui allaient
pouvoir voter et 3 et 4 décembre
prochain et peut-être une semaine après
s'il y a un deuxième tour et
l'ampleur de cette mobilisation montre
que et bien cette élection interne
mobilise mobilise votre attention
mobilise votre engagement et je veux
vous en remercier en tout cas nos
candidats font preuve d'une
détermination qui est encourageante pour
l'avenir et je veux les en remercier si
vous avez suivi le débat sur LCI dans le
cadre de la élection à la présidence de
notre mouvement vous avez pu constater
que nos trois candidats certes
différents dans leur parcours leurs
origines leur tempérament ont pu
exprimer la richesse de leur conviction
et que et bien la richesse de ces points
de vue n'exclut pas l'esprit de
rassemblement ils ont contredit tous
ceux qui espèrent des divisions de la
désunion au contraire
se débat a montré que nous sommes non
seulement solides mais aussi résistant
la campagne va se poursuivre le prochain
rendez-vous auquel je vous convie soit
si vous êtes conseiller national en
présence au siège de notre mouvement
soit à suivre sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est le Conseil national qui est en
quelque sorte le Parlement du parti ce
conseil national qui aura lieu le 26
novembre prochain
au siège de notre mouvement
permettra l'audition de nos trois
candidats et vous pourrez leur poser les
questions que vous souhaitez donc je
vous donne rendez-vous le 26 novembre
prochain matin ou siège de notre
mouvement et puis bien sûr pour le
premier tour de l'élection les trois et
quatre décembre prochain et
éventuellement s'il y avait un deuxième
tour une semaine après les 10 et 11
décembre en tout cas merci pour votre
mobilisation je vous espère très
nombreux à exprimer votre vote qui
donnera une pleine légitimité à notre
futur président